تكثف الشرطه في مدينه فيلادلفيا في ولايه
بنسلفانيا الامريكيه جهودها للعثور على
امراه ارتكبت جريمه قتل راح ضحيطها طالب
سعودي مبتعث طعنا في وقت سابق هذا الاسبوع
الطالب المغدور يدعى الوليد الغريبي ووفقا
للشرط للشرطه تم العثور على جثته يوم
الاثنين مصابا بطعنه في الرقبه داخل
المبنى الذي يقتل فيه
مراسله العربيه
هل هناك من تفاصيل هل تم العثور على هذه
المراه وبحسب يعني المعلومات الوارده حتى
الان بانها هي مطلوبه اصلا في جرائم قتل
راويه اخر الانباء التي وصلتنا وذلك دائما
وفقا لصاحبه هذا المنزل الذي شاركتها
شاركها مكتب التحقيقات في شرطه جيرمن تاون
ارسلوا لها رساله اكدوا لها بانه القي
القبض على المتهمه بقتل الطالب السعودي
وليد الغريبي التي الامريكيه والتي تدعى
نيكول ميري وذلك دائما بحسب صاحبه هذا
المنزل عندما حاولنا الاتصال بمكتب الشرطه
يؤكد لنا هذا الخبر وقالوا بانهم سيفون
بمزيد من التفاصيل لاحقا وتاكيد هذا الخبر
الان نحن امام المنزل الذي كان مسرح ل-
جريمه القتل التي راح ضحيتها طالب السعودي
وليد الغريبي في هذا المنزل تحديدا هنا
همم غرفه همم الوليد الغرفه التي يقطنها
كان همم المغدور وليد الغريبي همم في همم
التي كان يسكنها ايضا منذ يوليو الماضي
تحديدا عند هذه الكنبه تحديدا كان يجلس
الوليد دائما بابتسامه مرتبه بحسب صاحبه
المنزل همم وايضا دعيني اشير الى هذه
الكاميرا تحديدا هنا التي همم اخذت صور
للملتهمه عندما غادرت المنزل مسرعه بعد
ارتكابها همم للجريمه همم تحمل كيس همم
اسود
تظن الشرطه بانها بهذا الكيس اداه الجريمه
الاساسيه صاحبه المنزل كانت عندما كانت
تبكي الوليد وقالت بانه من الطف الاشخاص
الذين تعرفت عليهم هو دائم الابتسامه همم
يهتم بالجميع كان الوحيد الذي يلقي التحيه
على الاخرين ويهتم
ايضا عندما تاتي لتطمئن همم على القاطنين
في هذا المنزل مثل ما فهمنا من صاحبه
المنزل بانه همم يتم تاجيل الغرف لعده
اشخاص اا المتهمه بارتكاب الجريمه نيكول
ماري همم
استاجرت غرفه لمده 18 عبر موقع اير بي ان
بي وفي اليوم الاخير همم
لها في هذا المنزل همم تم استدعاء صاحبه
المنزل من قبل قاتلين اخرين الذين قالوا
بانهم سمعوا اصوات غريبه
وضربات غريبه في الطابق الثالث حيث قتل
همم
وعندما وصلت صاحبه المنزل وجدتها في
الطابق الثالث تنظف بطريقه غريبه عندما
سالتها لماذا تنظفين بهذا الشكل قالت لها
لا اود ان اترك اي اوساخ هنا همم ثم
تشاجرت هي واياها وعلى الفور غادرت
المتهمه بطريقه غريبه ما جعل صاحبه المنزل
تتفقد المنزل
ووجدت الحمام في الطابق الثالث مغلق حاولت
فتحه ولكنها لم تستطع بعد عده محاولات
تمكنت من خلع الباب لتجد الوليد طارقا في
دماؤه متكئا على حوض الحمام حاولت انعاشها
ولكنها لم تستطع اتصلت بالشرطه عند بعد ما
وصلت الشرطه بعد عشر دقائق تقريبا همم
اعلنوا وفاته
اياها صاحبه المنزل
اتفضل ايه اكملي هاي النقطه ما هي
الملاحظات
نقطه مهمه انه الملاحظه التي ذكرتها لنا
صاحبه المنزل بانه نيكول ميري لو طالما
علقت على الوليد بطريقه غريبه وقالت
لصاحبه المنزل بانه ااه لديه اغراض ثمينه
من الموبايل همم خاصه همم الكمبيوتر
المحمول خاصه وايضا سيارته سمينه جدا همم
لديه هو غني جدا همم وبعد الجريمه عندما
حاول صاحبه المنزل همم التاكد من غرفه همم
الوليد يعني وجدت الكاميرا داخل الغرفه
مقفله واغراض مفقوده تمام يعني الشرطه
هناك معلومات وربما الشرطه الجريمه كان
سرقه لانه كان هناك حديث عن انه همم كان
همم الوليد يريد ان يتخلص من بعض الاثاث
همم واعلن عن ذلك على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي فيسبوك تحديدا ليبيعها ومن ثم
جاء
صحيح عندما توصلنا نعم
عندما تواصل التواصلنا مع الشرطه طلبوا
منها بان همم نتعامل مع هذه المعلومات
لانها غير دقيقه وسيشاركون معنا التفاصيل
الدقيقه حتى سالنا صاحبه المنزل اذا ما
كانت هذه المعلومه صحيحه ونفت تماما وقالت
انه كان هذا اليوم الاخير لنيكول ميري في
هذا المنزل همم
العقد الذي تم عبر اير بي ان بي وهمم تنجح
صاحبه المنزل بانه لكل ميري طلبت من
الوليد مساعدتها لنقل اغراضها لذلك
استدرجته الى الطابق الثالث لانه هذه
الغرفه في الطابق الاسفل هي غرفه نعم شكرا
جزيلا لك سليمان مراسله العربيه كانت معنا
من كان